a given quadratic could have conceived
her or one or two weeks
right um not quite the discriminant says
you can zero one or two real roots but
when you're even reached in general off
of any nature a quadratic has to have
two it must have two okay they might be
complex which we don't have to really
worry about yet but they're there if it
exists they could be equal well they
could be distinct in the room which is
nowhere normally used to dealing okay so
I'm going to call them alpha and beta
they have to be - okay all right now
how do I get the relationship between
this the roots and these coefficients
here a B and C well if this quadratic
has roots of alpha beta okay
we often when you get a quadratic right
we like three ways of finding what the
roots out whatever were the three
methods number one you can back your
eyes number two formula number three
complete this way good okay now um when
you get this first one here my
factorization we prefer this one because
it's the fastest right as the most
obvious okay so if I were to factorize
something and it had roots alpha and
beta what would its factorization be
good X minus Alpha X minus beta okay
that quadratic has roots okay no I want
this quadratic right to be equal to the
one I started with ax squared plus BX
plus C okay I want to approach the same
quadratic from two different angles as
it were okay this is from the general
angle right and this is from the angle
of what roots it has no I'm almost done
here
terms of my sin are okay but not quite
finished because at least how I look at
it and this equation can almost never be
true
almost this equation could only be true
when a is equal one why
good good good so in case you didn't
catch that right if you have a look on
the right hand side here right it's it's
like you collected like terms and it's
finished all the like terms are gathered
together all the x-squared to hear all
of the answers are here ignore the
constant sit here okay now when you look
at this no matter how you expend it no
matter how you rearrange and do all
kinds of weird stuff right you're never
gonna get an a out in front you're out
of square right because all of the X
squares well there's only going to be
one of them right because they come from
these two terms okay so this Y only
works in this case so I want to fix that
right so what I'm gonna do is if I want
a what's an x squared on both sides I'm
going to slap an a okay okay now this is
actually gonna work so let's expand this
out and see what happens
Bevin's when you expand this i'm gonna
have x squared minus X minus Alpha X
plus alpha beta x squared so let's see
right here this is a bit of a mess so is
this what can I do here maybe books two
options I think you can stand that out
with the a right or you could take the a
over the other side okay now I think
either way would work but I think if I
take the air of this other side the
results were after me a little bit more
obvious okay so I'm going to divide
everything by a alright so I've got this
and if I'm dividing everything by a over
here this becomes Manik this becomes B
over a X and this becomes C over a
divide every time yeah okay now what's
happening over here on the left hand
side I want to rearrange it so it's more
similar to this side okay so my X
Squared's they're fine
okay so I'll just leave them alone what
am I got here I've got a bit of a jumble
where it is over here I've got one less
and me I've got all the XS together
right so I'm gonna take all of these
guys and I'll factor out yes so I get x
squared minus okay so what's the double
negative okay there's my half a better
okay now what does this mean because
I've got all the X Squared's here in
here right all the X is here in here and
all the constants here in here
right they don't mix it's a bit like
like oil and water
okay these parts aren't going to
magically turn into a constant and these
parts are going to magically turn to an
X or vice versa
okay so my next line would be by
comparison of coefficients you see
that's what I'm doing here I'm looking
at each side and say the coefficients
should match up I've got X Squared's
over here they line up I've got X's over
here they should line up too right so
minus alpha plus beta that's the
coefficient on the left hand side should
be equal to be on a okay
or pattern more familiar with looking at
it without the negative side on that
side there's the result okay and in the
same way just looking at the end here
right
alpha beta the product of the roots is
CLA
okay now I think that's probably the
quickest way to derive these results
it's really simple algebra actually you
could probably use half as many lines as
I did but I just want to make it super
super obvious Oh
however you might not like that way
because it seems a bit seems a bit black
magic to me like why did you do that
why did I even stop with this line okay
so let me show you just quickly okay
just so you got more tools in your
toolbox and maybe you prefer this method
if I'm after the sum and product of
roots okay the more direct way to go
after them it's just a say what are the
roots are and then add them up that'll
give you the Sun and then say what the
grits are and what's the product
multiply them okay see what you get
so if I've got alpha and beta I actually
know what they value so alpha would
probably be one of this that's one of
the roots isn't it what's the other one
it's just with a with an addition right
it's the conjugate if you like okay now
if this is wondering this is the other
what is the sum
it's the style now you're looking at it
at at first and you can that's really
gross I look at all this business but
actually when you add them up because of
this negative and it's positive that's
gonna cancel right with the disgusting
Club so I'm gonna get minus B and minus
B it's the two parts that actually count
right although by the same denominator
yeah -
oh that was kind of yeah right I'm just
adding up the roots in the same way if
you multiply the roots again it looks as
if it will be very bad as if it will
come out terrible numbers turn off
letters sorry but because they're
conjugates because they conjugate this
is actually a factorization you learn
all the way back in here
I might've even been you seven there's
the what's the see I'm a topical what is
this is the difference right I know it's
confusing with the A's and B's but this
is a minus B and a plus B right so the
result should be a squared minus B
squared well the first thing squared is
B squared right in this second thing
because it's a square root and just turn
into that like you see that's just the
square roots gone sweat seeing it be
Squared's cancel okay
negatives cancel fours cancel a cancels
with that a okay so which one you prefer
is up to you I mean it's kind of cool
that doing it this way both results just
sort of fall out okay but this one's
sort of like well I want the some sort
so you take whichever